you're buying a fresh turkey you want to
buy it at least two days in advance
you're buying a frozen turkey you're
going to want to buy it five days in
advance when buying your turkey you want
to plan on leaving about a pound and a
half per person if you're cooking for a
large crowd you're better off getting
two smaller birds instead of one massive
one with a bigger turkey it's going to
take so long to cook by the time the
whole bird is cooked through the outside
is going to be almost inedible the
safety concerns you want to focus on
when thawing your turkey in the fridge
is making sure that you're first putting
your turkey on some sort of baking tray
to catch any juices if they leak through
the bag also keeping it on the bottom
will ensure that there's nothing below
it you don't want raw turkey juice all
over your fridge with a fresh turkey you
still want to buy it early because the
refrigerators at the grocery store are
much colder than what you have at home
and it's still going to be pretty solid
so you want to make sure that it's
totally defrosted in your fridge for a
day if your turkey's frozen there's two
ways to defrost it one you could do it
in the fridge you could also do a
quicker method by sticking your turkey
in a big sink or even a cooler and
filling it up with fresh cold water
every 30 minutes until it's totally
defrosted you should allow about 30
minutes to thaw for each pound of turkey
a day before you're going to cook your
turkey you're going to want to brine it
there's two different kinds of ways to
brine the traditional method is to wet
brine which basically means sitting your
turkey in a salt water solution we're
gonna do a dry brine which just means
we're just gonna rub salt all over it
it's a little bit less wasteful and also
easier to do first things first you're
gonna measure out the amount of salt you
need you're going to want to take a look
at the weight of your turkey and use
half a teaspoon per pound before i get
the turkey out you want to get a few
things ready to go make sure you have a
garbage nearby a pair of kitchen shears
a plastic bag and a fresh baking tray
with a rack on it so you want to cut the
plastic off the bird making sure not to
cut the skin or flush of the turkey and
remove the turkey from the whole bag and
then take that baking tray away with the
bag and replace it with the fresh baking
tray with the rack on it so then we're
gonna get our bag ready to go and we're
gonna start cutting off any excess that
we definitely aren't gonna use if
there's extra skin around the neck you
can go ahead and cut that off then turn
your bird around and if the turkey legs
are secured in that plastic holder go
ahead and release them so that you can
easily get into the cavity so then
you're going to reach in and grab any
innards or a bag of giblets and some
people use these for gravy but in this
recipe we're not going to so you can
just discard them and then using a
disposable paper towel dry off your bird
by patting it on all sides and all the
crevices lift the legs left the arms and
make sure the whole bird is dry so that
the salt will stick to the skin so you
can start by just sprinkling the salt
all over the bird and again you're going
to want to get under all the arms and
all the crevices in the cavity on top of
all the skin turn the bird over just
salt the entire thing to make sure that
it's coated entirely in salt and then
you're going to put it in the fridge
uncovered for one day if you're going to
brown any longer than that you're going
to want to cover it with cling film
until a day before and then you can take
off the cling film and let the skin dry
out and this process is going to work as
a flavor enhancer it's also going to
allow the meat to hold on to more
moisture and dry out the skin so it's
nice and crispy you're going to want to
start prepping your turkey for cooking a
few hours before you want to serve it
but again that's going to largely depend
on the weight of your turkey before you
get your turkey out you're going to make
a butter mixture and you can put
whatever you want here you want to start
with some softened butter we chose to go
with fresh sage chopped garlic dried
thyme and dried rosemary we used a
smaller amount of dried thyme and
rosemary because those are quite strong
it's going to be a much more powerful
flavor than fresh herbs then you're
going to mash all that together you can
do this a day in advance all the way up
to just before you prep the turkey and
once that's all ready to go just leave
it off to the side and preparation for
your turkey so to roast your turkey you
can use one of the more traditional
roasting pans or you can use one of the
one time use aluminum trays they're
cheap they're easy it's also great if
you don't have a lot of storage in your
kitchen just put a baking tray
underneath it for support a lot of
roasting pans will come with this rack
but we're actually not going to use it
it doesn't allow for great air
circulation underneath the turkey and
leaves for a soggy bottom as well as a
longer cooking time so first we're going
to cut off the wingtips and you're going
to feel for the joint and then cut right
in the middle of that and then put the
wingtips into the roasting pan to use
for the gravy and next we want to cut
off the wishbone and this is going to
make your life a lot easier when you're
carving later and the easiest way to do
that is to cut off any extra skin so you
can see the wishbone and you'll see kind
of this white outline that looks like a
wishbone and then you're going to get in
with a little paring knife and you want
to cut the flesh on either side of the
bone slowly work your way from the tip
all the way down to the two legs and
then you can go in with your finger and
kind of tug at it and it should come
loose and if it's still pretty stuck to
the bones you can also use kitchen
shears to cut it loose and then you can
kind of get your hand in there and twist
the top off and once you release the
wishbone you can throw that in the
roasting tray as well for gravy and then
you can move the roasting tray aside for
now to make more room and then turn the
birds that the legs are facing towards
you if your turkey came with one of
those plastic holders we want to get rid
of that before we cook it so you can
kind of reach in there and give it a
good tug and it should come out pretty
easily so now you want to start
loosening the skin from the breast to
make room for some butter and you're
going to peel the skin up a little bit
and then use your fingers to release the
skin from the breast and you can also
use a rubber spatula instead of your
hands just be careful that you don't
pierce the skin and putting the butter
under the skin is going to keep the
breast moist as well as keep the skin
crispy and it also means we're not going
to have to baste the bird because we
have the butter already trapped in here
and that will again result in crispier
skin once you're happy you have enough
of the herb butter under the skin you're
going to rub the rest of the butter all
over the remainder of the bird and
similar to the other steps you want to
make sure you're getting in every
crevice lift up the legs turn it over
fully season the bird and the herb
butter if you have any remaining butter
you can rub a little bit of that inside
all around the cavity as well and
instead of stuffing we're going to put
just a few aromatics in but not too many
that is going to block the airflow and
this will give it a little bit of extra
flavor while leaving plenty of room for
hot air to flow through during cooking
and then with the rest of the onion you
can chop that up throw it in the
roasting pan with a chopped up carrot
and a little bit of celery as well for
flavor and then empty a carton of
chicken broth into the roasting pan as
well and then to avoid any mess on the
way to the oven you can place your rack
on top of the roasting tray just to
avoid any dripping in your kitchen and
then any juices that came out of the
turkey when you were buttering it can go
in as well this isn't a super
traditional gravy but it's going to give
you tons of flavor and all the drippings
from the cooking of the turkey will drip
into the roasting pan and flavor the
gravy as well you want to place the
roasting pan on the lowest rack of your
oven and then with the turkey on that
baking rack you're going to put that
directly on the oven rack right above
the roasting tray we baked our turkey at
325 for about two hours but what you're
really looking for is to make sure that
the turkey is reading at 165 degrees
fahrenheit before serving it but take it
out of the oven when it reaches 160
degrees fahrenheit and while it's
resting the temperature will continue to
rise an extra five or so degrees it's a
good idea to start checking it about 90
minutes in the turkey is going to cook a
lot quicker in this method because you
haven't stuffed the cavity and there's
more air flow all around the bird you're
gonna rest the bird for about 20 to 30
minutes before you start carving it and
juices might still flow out of it a
little bit so it's a good idea to put
this on a baking rack just to catch any
of those juices and in the meantime you
can finish off the gravy so then we're
going to take out all the larger pieces
that we can grab with tongs and then
you're going to strain the gravy over a
pot and then at this point you're going
to bring this to a boil and reduce that
and let it thicken this stock is good to
use as is and it will soak right into
the turkey but if you want it a little
bit thicker ladle a few spoonfuls into a
small bowl filled with two tablespoons
of flour and really beat it to make sure
that there's no lumps and then you can
kind of gradually stir a bit into the
gravy and as the gravy boils that's
what's going to trigger the flour to
thicken the sauce so wait till it boils
first before you decide if you need more
to keep it warm while you carve you can
put it on a very low heat on the
stovetop at this point and just stir it
every few minutes you can put it in a
gravy boat at this point you can put it
in a thermos even to keep it really warm
or you can just reheat it right before
you serve it giving it a quick whisk to
smooth it out again so first we're going
to transfer the turkey onto a large
cutting board with a lip to catch any
juices to stabilize the bird you can
release the legs from the body and then
that will make it a little bit easier to
carve it and to do that you're going to
find where the leg kind of meets the
breast cut down that line and kind of
follow the same line and you don't have
to cut all the way through at this point
you're just kind of going to get it
started you can use your hands to pull
the leg and the thigh off the carcass at
this point the hip joint should pop out
pretty easily and to make it even more
stable you can tuck that leg underneath
the wing bone to cut off the breasts
you're going to find the breastbone
which is right down the middle and then
you're going to cut just on the side of
that you can go almost straight down
kind of following the line of the
breastbone and this should be pretty
easy since we did the work earlier
removing the wishbone you're going to
cut down as far as you can and then if
you need to release it you can cut
horizontally right by the wing and
release the breast from the carcass and
when you were pulling the legs if you
weren't able to release the hip joint
from the carcass just go through at this
point and cut all the way through that
joint and release any extra skin or meat
that's still connected to the carcass
and we'll put this aside and finish
cutting it later the wings can be a
little tricky as well to release the
wings you're looking to find where the
shoulder meets the breast if you're
having a lot of trouble with it you can
just actually use your hands to release
the joint and then once you kind of pop
it out then you can use your knife to
finish the job so if you had any
remaining breast meat that you weren't
able to get off when you cut the breast
off the first time that'll come off when
you remove the wing don't throw this
away just yet inevitably there's going
to be a little bit of meat left on the
carcass after dinner you can always get
the remaining meat off of there and you
can use that for leftovers later or use
the whole carcass in a soup we'll start
with the breast and what we're going to
do is get it back on your cutting board
what you're doing here is cutting across
the grain and that'll make it more
tender and also it's going to give
everyone a piece of the crispy skin
instead of that one lucky person if you
were to cut slices off the bird and you
can set those aside on your platter and
for the leg we're going to cut the
drumstick off of the thigh what you're
trying to do is cut through the joint
which should happen pretty easily but
it's kind of difficult to find so you
can kind of do an exploratory cut and
get through the flush so you can see
where you're going and you can kind of
wiggle your knife to find it if it's
really difficult you should probably
just pick up your knife and try a
different area or once you've cut most
of the meat you can use your hands to
just kind of pop the joint off now you
can put the drumstick on the platter and
with the thigh we're going to cut the
meat off the bone you can turn the thigh
over and see where the bone is and then
cut on either side and then just cut
that into bite-size pieces and for the
wings you're just going to cut through
this joint so you're just going to cut
off the skin and any meat that's on
there and then you can use your hands to
release the flat from the wing and once
you pop the joint you can use your knife
to cut through any remaining skin or
meat and you can cut off any extra
breast meat that was left on the wing
now that you have all the meat on the
platter you can kind of rearrange it and
make sure that it's nice and presentable
and you can put the nicer parts with a
nice brown crispy skin on top maybe the
kind of more random pieces underneath
that and it's a nice finishing touch you
can add some fresh sage if you have any
leftover for color maybe some lemons
it's gonna be a nice way to cover up any
imperfections but also just add a nice
kind of bright freshness cooking a
turkey can be a daunting task but this
recipe is great because it's so simple
it's low maintenance and it's really
delicious now's the best part you get a
douse it in gravy and everyone can tell
you how delicious your turkey is
you did it it wasn't that hard and you
know it's beautiful and everyone's going
to appreciate your work no matter what
and if they don't make them do the
dishes